good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters is
the character of Ben in your book Paper
Towns based on anyone you knew in high
school yes
myself is it still possible to be a
secret sibling yeah just make video
responses everyone who makes video
responses is a secret sibling how's
NaNoWriMo going mm it's going okay but
I'm 10,000 words behind because I've had
to work on the Paper Towns screenplay
revision house paper town screenplay hmm
going okay but I'm a little bit behind
because I've had to work on NaNoWriMo
what is love baby don't hurt me don't
hurt me no more what's up with the beard
it makes you look like a creeper I'm
growing the beard for something called
Movember in which lots of people grow
unusual facial hair in order to raise
money for prostate cancer research so
anyway someone offered some money to
prostate cancer research if I grew the
beard for the whole month your question
ought to be why is Hank currently
clean-shaven in clear support of
prostate cancer wait who the eff is Hank
Hank is an optical disc originally
created to store sound recordings but
these days many different kinds of data
are recorded on Hank it takes how I'm
gonna be on iTunes it already is on
iTunes link in the doobly-doo but I
would recommend that you consider buying
the actual physical Hank because that
comes with a poster why don't you like
unicorns do you at least like glitter
I don't like unicorns because they
refuse to disarm and become horses they
insist on walking around with those
deadly weapons attached to their faces
but yeah I love glitter specifically
glittery unicorn poison how do you feel
about fruit cake it's kind of a unicorn
of a cake genre to me I want to buy
Hanks album but I don't have any money
though your question is not technically
a question nor in fact I might convince
that it's a sentence but I want to help
you for 48 hours from the moment this
video goes live I will give you two
dollars seriously so here's what I'm
gonna do it hangs on I'm going to find
out about it for like a week because
he's on tour for the next two days if
you go to the link in the doobly-doo
dftba.com slash John is giving me $2
your CD will only cost $13 and then I
will pay the other $2 to Hank
also I think I'm gonna pay him in two
dollar bills because I have a ton of $2
bills and lately I've been like what do
you do with these things oh and if
you're mad because you already bought
the CD and so I'm not giving you two
dollars here's a $2 hug
it's just for you can you feel it I can
feel it feels good
that's enough starting to get a little
awkward huh okay I'm gonna it's okay
that was nice though glad we have that
are your books in Serbian amazingly yes
check out my Serbian name it's like John
Green
or maybe it's Dijon grin do you have any
tips on coming out to my parents I think
all you can do is be honest I mean the
hard part isn't the part where you say
I'm gay the hard part is where you have
to be understanding of however they
respond good luck I'm rooting for you
have we found Gus as a bug yet yes what
I could not do for three years
nerdfighteria did collectively in like
20 minutes
so the Gus book is currently on its way
to my house nerdfighters please keep
sending in your awesome Gus
illustrations and congratulations now
you get to punish me yay
the official thread for discussing
punishments can be found at a link in
the doobly-doo nerdfighters there's some
video of Hank on tour in the doobly-doo
I've been pointing in the wrong
direction this entire time or am i
pointing in the right direction
god I hate directions anyway there's a
bunch of tour videos in the doobly-doo
and Hank I'll see you tomorrow